each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
we'll get started with two talks on
music and audio processing so first we
have Eric Battenberg from UC Berkeley
all right my name is Eric Battenberg and
I'm with the Center for new music and
audio technologies and the par lab at UC
Berkeley we call the this this place
send Matt for short that's that cool
symmetric logo up there next to our
bridge and this talk is entitled the
breadth of applications for music and
I'm not going to be focusing on one
particular application but a few
different things we're working on it
send Matt so there are hundreds
literally hundreds of applications for
music and also plugins and plugins are
things you can little pieces of code you
can use to extend existing music
applications so these are the four main
areas we're working on at Sen Matt and
at the par lab for music applications
the first is performance and composition
and put some cool logos to grab people's
attention here first guitar hero that's
you know one way to interact with a
computer musically also the max MSP
visual programming environment is
something that musicians have been using
a lot and protools is the most popular
audio editing software and that's just a
way for amateur musicians to edit their
audio at home second music information
retrieval and that's a lot like
content-based image retrieval it hasn't
seen much as as much academic attention
but there are companies popping up doing
doing a bit of this and then there's
also this ear calm Institute in France
that does a lot of research in that area
third hearing augmentation for music and
this is just for hearing-impaired people
to enjoy music more the types of
processing that you need to do to
enhance how music sounds for the hearing
impaired is is very different from what
you need to do to make speech more
intelligible so we're working on that
and this is a little a subjective space
that we train with a neural network that
enables
the hearing aid where to kind of
navigate around and decide on a fitting
that's best for them a set of parameters
that process the audio according to
their specific hearing loss and last is
three dimensional sound this is a large
arrays of speakers and microphones for
reproducing three dimensional sound
we're working with Meyer Sound and over
here we have an example of a 120 channel
spherical speaker rates about this big
and it's used to recreate really cool
three-dimensional sounds real sounding
instruments because you get really
interesting radiation patterns in real
life rather than just a single speaker
pointing in a certain direction so in
this talk a little bit of background on
music applications and then some
insights into music and parallel
computing the implications that music
applications have that the requirements
they need from parallel computing in
order to make it to work in order to
make it work and and then I'm going to
talk about a case study parallelizing
drum track extraction which is a
particular type of music information
retrieval source separation on OpenMP
and cuda these are this is targeting GPU
architectures and video GPUs and just
multi-core processors in general and but
before that i'm going to talk about a
little bit about how to communicate the
computational needs of this of this
project here using parallel design
patterns and this is just a high-level
way to kind of understand what the needs
are what what things are being done in
in my application and last a fun
brainstorm something cool the future of
music information retrieval and
hopefully it'll be a fun motivating
example so for music composition we're
working with different musical
interfaces electronic interfaces these
two are developed at send Matt this is a
touch-sensitive with drum with
conductive fabric you can do interesting
signal processing on that we have this
24 pad multi-touch array that is
pressure and location sensitive and
David Wessel performs some interesting
pieces with this and last we're not
working
directly on this but we are somewhat
involved this is a react to bowl react
yeah reactable it's a it's a cool table
where you place these little tangibles
they call them little things on here and
make really cool music i suggest you
google that because it's a really cool
example and it's really easy for novices
to play around with and make really cool
sounds for audio editing and audio
recording there are tons of amateur
musicians nowadays making affordable
home studio just using a personal
computer a sound card and audio editing
software like Pro Tools and they call
this a digital audio workstation and you
can get really professional quality
sound out of these just using all these
audio effects if you have a good
microphone I guess I should have put a
microphone on there too that would be
part of the cost so the power of these
digital audio workstations lies in
plugins these are just little little
things you can buy that that incorporate
different effects compressors to get the
levels balance a different cool effects
that like auto-tune has anyone familiar
with autotune this is not not auto
tuning like like a colonel but like
auto-tune that t-pain uses to make to
make him sound like a good singer when
he's not this that corrects your pitch
it's automatic pitch correction so
different plugins like rack and these
they're developed by third parties or
they're included with the with the audio
editing software and when if we're going
to parallel lies these we need to ask
are they thread safe that is are we
going to get the same behavior out of
them regardless of how they're scheduled
on the machine or are we going to get a
crash are we going to get completely
different sounds out of these things if
they're scheduled differently and
there's different amounts of delays when
they're composed are they going to cause
catastrophic performance conflicts that
is our or is the performance just going
to become unbearably slow when when
these are competing for resources within
the application and last will they
appropriately share hardware resources
with other applications running on the
same machine because real time
performance is so important for audio
applications particularly live
performances the sharing as sharing
hardware resources is really important
so to answer these questions the part
lab has been working on two little
projects not little projects two big
projects this is a tes elation OS is is
how they're envisioning a space-time
partitioning amongst applications and
then down here is life and that's the
second level within your application how
are you partitioning resources amongst
the different libraries and call and
system calls so that you aren't you
aren't competing for cash destroying
your cash when your when your time
sharing time sharing a core and for the
0 at the OS level another thing that
music is going to need for real-time
performance is timing and deadlines
guarantees right so if you're doing
real-time performance and you don't meet
a deadline a timing deadline you're
going to get a click or a pop also if
two things are split on two different
cores they may end up being written to
the audio buffer at different times and
you'll get a completely different sound
out of it and I'll have an example of
that in a second so the next point I
want to make is that music is inherently
very parallel this is a this is just a
score of different instruments playing
and you can see all the voices it's like
20 30 something voices all going you
know in a very data parallel way but the
important thing here is that
synchronization audio synchronization
and timing are very important if these
things aren't occurring right in time
the year is going to be upset right so
timing is a here's an example it's going
to be an audio example hopefully you'll
be able to hear it if we have a copy of
a piece of audio and we process another
copy of it on a separate core and we
miss a deadline that is we the the audio
buffer needs to write to the digital
analogue converter at a certain time and
the other core doesn't meet that
deadline is going to be writing a frame
late right so if we're just delaying
another copy of the audio by one
millisecond we get this combing affect
anyone familiar with digital signal
processing to see that this is like a
comb filter we get these notches
in frequency and just with the one
millisecond delay i'm going to show you
example of this audio
noticeable did everyone hear the little
difference there it sounds a lot more
hollow right and went and we got this
combing effect it can just it wasn't
just distortion and clicks it was
actually like changing how the sound
sounds and and for people who are
spending tons of time getting the sound
just right on their compositions this is
very troublesome time it's like the main
reason that ear calm sort of abandoned
parallel audio processing but back in
the day because they couldn't get all
this timing right it would things would
just not sound deterministically correct
so one way around this is is open sound
control this is a standard developed
send Matt a near calm and and it's a way
to kind of communicate audio performance
data sort of like MIDI back and let
still use MIDI a little bit but it
operates over Ethernet and the important
thing for us here is that when you're
sending audio performance data you can
you can include these high-resolution
time tags and these time tags can be
used to use to synchronize right if
you'd say when when this audio event
occurred and and it arrives at the audio
buffer then then you know that you need
to delay something else if it has been
delayed in fact so then you get the
synchronization there alright so next
area which is my area I'm working on
music information retrieval and we call
that mere also MIT they have a machine
listening group we like to call it music
understanding because we feel that's a
little more all-encompassing than just
information retrieval unless you know
sort of capturing the psychological
aspect of a human experience with music
up here in the corner in the middle is
an audio waveform and this is an example
of music transcription it's you're
producing a musical score at the top
there from the audio of events also at
the bottom that's called a piano roll
notation or it's like a time time and
frequency or time note based plot that's
one application of music information
retrieval automatic transcription we can
also do source separation
is isolating different instruments for
analysis similarity playlist creation
playlist creation is I think the thing
that most people can wrap their heads
around is being useful just anyone who
listens to music say I'm in a mood for a
certain Led Zeppelin song that it
doesn't rock out too hard it's it's
pretty it's pretty easy listening but I
want to listen to some classic rock like
that I'll give it this led zeppelin song
and find me other songs like this and
make a playlist funny right instead of
just saying okay i'm into the mood for
this led zeppelin song and then i end up
listening to the rest of Led Zeppelin's
album and but that's usually how most
people listen to this stuff unless maybe
you go to Pandora or something right
Pandora will do that for you but at the
expense of your connected to their
server and also all that information
that they use for comparison is made by
humans so people are listening to the
music checking off different aspects of
it maybe that's not the category you
want to be comparing okay so also we can
classify by mood artist score following
is important for automated accompaniment
so if you want to play a solo instrument
and have the computer automatically
follow along where you are in the score
and play some computer instruments along
with you also lyric synchronization
that's for automatic karaoke and last
song segmentation splitting up a song
into verse chorus bridge etc because
they may be pretty different parts and
you can analyze them independently then
so the hope with all this technology is
that someday you can query for musically
like this I like the drummer but I can't
stand the singer find me something in
the same genre with drumming like this
but with a singer that sounds more like
John Lennon or Rod Stewart or someone
you really like right and this this
isn't that far-fetched this this cut
this kind of thing can be possible the
next few years alright so as a case
study for parallelizing music
information retrieval I looked at drum
track extraction and this is a
particular example of source separation
where you take an audio waveform in and
out put an audio waveform hopefully
containing only the drums or only the
percussion and this is done first
there's spectral feature extraction you
you take out a spectrogram and in this
case we're operating on about 20 seconds
of audio at a time then non-negative
matrix factorization that's nmf here is
used to split up the spectrogram matrix
into time and frequency components and
you can select the number of components
you want in this in this usually I use
about 30 components just in popular
music there's there's enough things
going on at once that 30 components
works pretty well and then you extract
features from the components so that you
can classify the components is either
percussive or not or drums or not and
then Yuri synthesized the audio
corresponding to those components right
and the important thing computationally
is that eighty percent of the time in a
matlab comput matlab implementation is
spent on the non-negative matrix
factorization that's the unsupervised
learning routine that is iterative and
it takes a lot of computation and so
it's in the matlab implementation this
is my optimized matlab implementation
some naive implementations take about 90
seconds to run on 20 seconds of audio
which is totally infeasible we got it
down about 23 seconds which people
asking like how did you optimize matlab
right it's it's matlab but i mean
avoiding you know for loops using single
precision when you when you don't need
to use double precision audio is very
single precision the samples are 16 bits
usually that's how we got it down also
not computing things some people do some
silly stuff in malibu anyway we got it
down to about almost real-time 23
seconds but we're going to paralyze this
and try to get it you know down a lot
using openmp for multi-core machines and
cuda for GPUs yeah the SDM um it's very
tedious Lee I did I ran it on lots of
clips of audio listen to the components
drums not drums drums not drums I made a
little interface to do it really quickly
yeah I hand did it about a hundred clips
of audio and then I cross-validated
everything pretty pretty good results
the classification is two or three
percent error rate actually yeah so
here's some audio examples
and also you get a prize if you name the
artist and an song I'll buy you a beer
at next year's Babs workshop or
something and if you just know the
artist then you're the person sitting
next to you owes you a high five all
right let's go number one everyone
else's this is hopefully some people
probably know what the song is right
black magic woman
now it's important to listen to the
audio to the drums the original version
most people just hear Santana playing
right if you're a drummer you might have
heard all these drums here now the drums
aren't I mean it did a pretty good job
of separating out you don't hear the
guitar at all right the drums aren't the
most they're not completely pleasing
sounding because the way the
non-negative matrix factorization works
is it is it has to smash out the
frequency components all the
contributions from all the guitar stuff
so that that stuff can be compensated
for later we didn't do any fancy signal
processing at the end this is just the
raw output of the non-negative matrix
factorization so but also this can be
used for drum track drum transcription
other kinds of things okay here's the
next song this will be a different
does anyone know who this is no one an
entire room No Outkast anyone heard of
outcasts they there they wrap their a
rap group it's a different kind of music
from Santana all right this is done
completely automatically so I didn't do
this by hand or anything
raise your hand if you know the name of
this song is it raise your hand if you
know the artist for three people all
right Led Zeppelin there they're a band
too there is some kind of new band
they're like just came out with this
song it's called Black Dog here there's
a little bit of distortion of the
spectrum and a little bit of influence
of the space on the phase from the
singer's voice and the guitars and stuff
but it does a pretty good job all right
so here's what kind of what comes out of
the non-negative matrix factorization
this is an audio spectrogram here it's
kind of flipped upside down so it looks
like a matrix but it's aligned with the
drum score here this is just this is
just only drums here so to get an idea
of what comes out of this factorized
into three components and the three
components these are the spectral
contributions or whenever whenever
something occurs in this row here were
we're positively scaling the
contribution of this part to the
spectrum here and this is the time the
the time contribution of each of the
components and it's aligned with the
drum track here so you can see all the
hi-hat hits are lining up with the
hi-hats and the score and the bass drum
and snare drum etc yeah looks like it's
a hi-hat depend on how hard they hit the
high-hat doesn't it change the camber
and it does yes um so this the reason
non-negative matrix factorization works
pretty well for drums is that the
spectrum is a spectrum for a drum is
fairly stationary how hard you hit it it
definitely changes the tambor and if you
are this is a very candid sample because
these are I just synthesized this using
the same drum sound each time so the
reason you use more than more than the
number of instruments you have as the
number of components is because
sometimes things sound different right
so if you're going to hit the snares I'm
really hard that the tambor will change
that will end up being a different
component but as long as it's classified
in the end as drums as a spectrum that
sounds like drums
or a time component that sounds like
drums it'll end up in the drum track at
the end ya see your drum will be
different instruments yes that's true
yea it hit it hit it harder hit it on
the rim hit it on the side different
sounds yeah alright so non-negative
matrix factorization is an optimization
problem and the important thing here is
that we're minimizing cost function and
instead of just using a mean squared
error for for the the reconstruction
between the product of those two
matrices and the original matrix we're
going to use this divergence function
it's similar to the Kobuk leibler
divergence it's a log based function and
this has been shown to work well for
music and the important thing here is
these are the gradient based updates
that that minimize this and this cost
function here is not convex in both W
and H so we will be arriving at a local
minimum and some people get around this
by doing the doing the optimization
multiple times and using the best result
but it is you do come up with a non
global solution but it still works
pretty well most of the time
computationally for a typical 20 seconds
of audio is a your factorizing a 512 by
about 3,000 matrix and we do it in in
230 sources so for each iteration this
can be broken down into about 400 mega
flops of single precision matrix
multiplies and 3.6 mega flops of divides
which are pretty slow for those of you
who yeah groups loves Chris Aiken yes um
I I usually use lower case when I'm
number of operations and all upper case
what is what is the convention is there
a convention for number of flops per
second okay yeah and then also important
for parallel we have some sums here it's
not much work but if you're going to
paralyze this on to a lot of threads it
requires a lot of communication to do
sums in this way and also we do some
other things here compute a log base
cost function every 25 iterations which
is pretty slow because logs are slow
so how can I communicate to you what
what this app involves what what the
important design considerations were in
this application how can I come up with
some jargon that'll help you understand
what went into this and also communicate
to other application experts like Jim
demo what I what I need out of this
application and one thing we're working
on this is sort of a plug for something
we're working on at UC Berkeley is this
parallel design pattern language and we
call it opl it's just a working name our
pattern language but it's hierarchical
and you start up here with I don't know
if you can read all this but for example
dense linear algebra is is is one of the
computational patterns here and
depending upon what architecture I'm
parallelizing this on this may be
decomposed into different patterns down
here so dense linear algebra we're doing
some matrix multiplication we're using
this pattern for doing it if we're going
to do a block decomposition we can use
the geometric decomposition pattern
later on maybe distributed array pattern
and some simdi so they'll all just be
these patterns will be decomposed
hierarchically and the importance of
this is a to help communicate to new
parallel programmers or just programmers
in general who are starting in starting
with this sort of high performance
computing jargon here about the best
practices about me because HPC has been
parallel computing has been going on for
a long time in hpc community only with
applications developers has it been
starting up more recently gives us a
common terminology and helps guide the
design process okay so yeah next we
actually we're having a joint workshop
with the CRC Illinois and and Berkeley
to discuss this pattern language
right out of our laboratory so if any of
you guys are staying are coming for the
proud that you can stay and visit all
right so for example just this leg of
the of the iterations updating the H
which is the time contributions we can
decompose this into this little bot
block diagram of matrix multiplies
element divides and then column sums and
and then when we decompose this into the
pattern language we start with this
high-level compositional structure just
pipe and filter basic consumer producer
architecture and within that we have
little blocks that are made up of matrix
multiplies sums and element wise
arithmetic which is completely data
parallel and and sort of naive here but
for example in the sums we apply the
MapReduce pattern which is just an
example of a way to do a reduction some
is a particular example of a reduction
and then in CUDA which we are arc which
we are targeting with this particular
implementation we use the graph
algorithms pattern which is we're doing
the reduction using a binary tree so we
are traversing this binary tree in a
particular way and the pointers in the
graph algorithm pattern the its actual
document to the each of these
corresponds to an actual document
written about the best practices and
pointers to helpful resources for
programming these things that can be
decomposed all the way down to simdi and
collective synchronization on the cuda
architecture so hopefully you have a
better idea of like what goes into this
all the computation here we have the
matrix multiplies sums and element wise
arithmetic okay so for the openmp
implementation it was really easy i did
this in like 30 minutes and i took my
sequential code wrote some reduction
routines wrote some data for parallel
for loops who's written OpenMP here
raise your hand everyone no not everyone
a lot of people right who's read about
OpenMP like who's seen this example for
OpenMP okay so so this all you need to
do is add one line and if your work is
is naively it is embarrassingly parallel
it'll just divide the work up a month
course so you add that in combination
with this reduction version of that you
just define the reduction operator
addition and the final variable that
you're going to be summing all the
partial sums into and each of these
threads can compute a partial sum right
so that's the openmp I did for this and
yeah it's really impressive right so we
use the math the Intel math kernal
library for all the matrix multiplies
which has uses openmp under the hood so
you can control the number of threads
there and we show the performance
scaling on a dual socket in a hail of
machine it goes from 11 and a quarter
seconds down to if 14 threads 2.6
seconds so we get a we get like about a
two time speed up going from one to two
threads but as we get to 14 we get to
the minimum it's definitely non linear
scaling so this probably won't scale
well to on the same architecture on the
using the same programming model though
we did get a seven times speedup
compared to the matlab implementation
which down to 2.6 seconds from 20 that's
getting pretty good for 20 seconds of
audio alright so CUDA I'm not going to
go d who who's actually programmed CUDA
ok that's good I'm not going to like get
into this you've probably seen this
before but the idea is you're running
lots of threads in CUDA and threads can
be grouped into thread blocks and within
thread blocks you can share memory and
that's how communication is done
physically these threads are executed in
groups of threads of 32 called warps and
if all the threads within a warp all do
the same thing then we get simdi right
so if threads within the same warp are
not doing the same thing this is called
this is called a divergent thread and
that means that all these threads are
going to be executed sequentially and we
lose the simdi speed up so but down here
we see an example of a CUDA kernel which
is run on the GPU and this is just
accomplishing element-wise addition and
each thread here just does one edition
so you launch the number of threads
which is the note this is the size of
your array and you call you call this
kernel down here using be
blocks be thread blocks of size and each
that's how you tell the current the
device how many threads to use and in it
and each of these threads operates on a
particular element computed from its
threat ID and its thread block ID and
everything so so luckily I didn't have
to program a matrix multiply in CUDA
that was taken care of for me by a one
of one of Jim students the Seelie heat
he came up with this really fast
implementation that achieve sixty
percent of peak on the gtx 280 about 370
mega flops so I found also that padding
my matrices to multiples of 32 because
it's that that worked pretty well it
decreased the running time by about
twenty six percent also the element-wise
arithmetic pretty naive it was similar
to the example on the previous page the
hardest thing to program though because
this wasn't provided in any libraries or
anything but I did find some good
pointers in the in the CUDA SDK about
how to optimize reduction parallel
reduction here so so parallel reduction
is accomplished in in kuda best using a
binary tree traversal so we each thread
copies memory to shared memory local
shared memory from global memory and
then we we do a series of two element
reductions down until we arrive at the
final sum now there's different ways of
organizing this different ways of
assigning threads and how they operate
on different elements and the optimal
way of doing that is to assign thread so
they're adjacent to one another and
assign them to have a straighted memory
access pattern and you can read about
that in if you're interested in the CUDA
programming manual but the important
thing here is that all the sums are are
adjacent right and then all the threads
that aren't working are adjacent as well
so you're avoiding divergent warps here
because here every other thread is not
working that's not simdi alright and
then applying these optimizations like
loop unrolling re organ so reorganizing
this this tree we're moving down we're
increasing the amount of up the number
of optimizations rear
izing the tree we get to here we apply
some loop unrolling and last running 30
sums concurrently so so there are 30
different sums in this non-negative
matrix factorization of length 5 12 now
those aren't very long sums they aren't
going to give us much work to parallel
lies so if we run them all concurrently
we get all the way down here to about 3
milliseconds from 155 milliseconds so
that was the most important optimization
yeah and that's that's a lot of work
just for a sum but it paid off and you
can see the results we get our original
optimize matlab implementation goes from
18.5 seconds all the way down 2.6
seconds that's like a little over 30 x
speed up we're doing 20 seconds of audio
and point six seconds which is pretty
good and the openmp implementation still
pretty good speed at 2.6 seconds for 20
seconds of audio and you can see that
the the s gem the multics multiplies is
like the main contributor the main thing
that achieves speed up here I don't know
why the matlab takes so long to do
element divides that's kind of silly
yeah so a important thing here CUDA
achieves a lot higher performance openmp
though a lot less work right so for
people do programming music applications
who aren't expert programmers who is
going to be a bit of a turn-off when you
introduce inner thread communication
through shared memory CUDA gets a heck
of a lot harder so so CUDA would only be
feasible for computational kernels that
require a lot of performance and also
for audio there's this question if we
haven't done this yet but how processing
audio in real time going back and forth
between the GP or are we going to be
able to achieve the achieve the latency
required and we're going to be releasing
Python modules for the music information
retrieval community so to finish up this
idea this a fun brainstorm idea combine
music informational gville analysis with
gestural processing or just interaction
with computers to come up with like a
custom music mix or a custom music
performance so this this is
applicable to automatic mashups which is
the buzzword now for taking things that
you didn't write and putting them
together and saying you did a gestural
music selection so you can imagine like
using that cool touch screen thing at
the Spitfire last night you have that on
a wall and you say I don't like this
song and based on all your so based on
all your preference personal preference
data an audio database in the cloud of
music and some music information
retrieval maybe we could navigate a
personal space of songs we like so let's
say we're at a party and the song is
just is too loud or it's too it's
getting everyone to routing you want to
tone it down a bit you can kind of
traverse you could traverse this space
come up to come come up with a point
where it fits the mood correctly and
just stop there so maybe seamlessly
moving between different songs until you
get to a point where you think it fits
your mood the best and then just leave
it there and let the computer decide
what fits that mood best you can combine
all of these music information retrieval
with gestural processing cool interfaces
and just come up with a with a you know
a custom audio mix and this this can be
used for music performance if you want
to accompany yourself with different
instruments pulled apart from different
pieces of music in recent the size later
is sort of a mashup or just for music
listening interactive music listening
where you're controlling your own
musical experience rather than just
clicking on individual songs it can be
very much personalized and you can have
as little or as much interaction as you
want right alright so to wrap up there
are lots of music applications and both
for musicians and for music fans
listeners and parallel computing enables
new applications that previous example
here will definitely be enabled by
parallel computing you know categorizing
tons of audio data processing these
complicated multi touch sensors that
will all be enabled in the future due to
parallel computing but synchronization
is really important as well
as timing is so important to the human
ear where need we're going to need to
put some emphasis on that for real real
time music and parallel design patterns
it's a cool way to organize to organize
and communicate your code and i
encourage you to at least look into that
as a way to instead of as a way to
communicate the computational needs of
that you have and last more than any
questions yeah some of the
experimentation with processing being
done in matlab yeah have you ever tried
their furlough two bucks you hadn't Asha
um the kernels that i wrote the
computational kernels that that are
being called in matlab here matrix
multiply F of tease those kinds of
things are already already parallelized
in MATLAB I guess so when I when I
quoted this number the number back there
that was the two threads on a laptop
right matlab automatically uses i don't
know what it uses under the hood but
it's calling blahs routines that are
that are already paralyzed I haven't
used matlab's parallel processing tool
box I don't yeah okay yeah okay I'm
Caleb loss um let's drill two lots and I
found it rather frustrating because the
way that it works is it spawns a new
process you can't actually spawn at
thread it spawns a new matlab process
and you're limited to only using four of
them so I have Anna Halen that has a
threads that I can't use the
because matlab's licenses for every core
it's about enabling domain-specific
languages are languages that are more
natural curve of a mess yeah curious in
theory there's any help that level of
abstraction it doesn't sound like it
does no baby steps but I don't think
there's quite there yet not in MATLAB
anyway my love is yeah licenses and
MATLAB is to proprietary I think a lot
of people are moving on the music
information retrieval community are
moving towards Python actually because
it's open source it's free and people
are writing cool modules I'm going to be
releasing python modules that you can be
that you can call from within Python to
run cuda code or run open PL versions of
this so open open MP versions of this so
yeah no more questions yeah Maxim is
pieces mean specifically yeah yeah max
MSP is a visual data flow language
that's that we're working on
parallelizing right now and a lot of
musicians use it I don't know if it's
the best for music information retrieval
but for live audio performance
definitely really good yeah when you're
doing the be nominated matrix
factorization g you get a little sleep
than once per song what you have to do
it but everything we do it every 20
seconds or it works best when you're
working on separate like chunks of audio
so 10 or 20 seconds of audio so for an
entire song you have to do it a few
different times yes what's the beginning
used to sing that
you could but the reason you want to
split it up is because instruments
change throughout us all if the song was
completely homogeneous the same drums
the same guitar the entire song it would
be easy to just do it once but that
would be a pretty boring song he right
now okay that's a tough act to follow
actually stuff to fit up to follow music
with boring old speech but hopefully
won't make it too boring you see the
title and I have in the mission to make
which is I don't actually care about
paralyzing speech recognition I care
about making it better but it turns out
that there are at least some
possibilities i think for making it much
better by using a lot more computation
and since the way the world seems to be
that to get more lots more computation
in the future we need the parallel lies
I'm interested I'm Morgan Adams annan's
here he'll be giving the second part of
the talk JK Chong couldn't make it he
did a lot of the work that Adam will
describe later on in the talk in
addition to his own work and of course
we're from Berkeley we're also from
international computer science institute
and closely affiliated institute a
couple blocks off campus so my fantasy
is that we can make speech recognition
much better by using a lot more
computation and having many streams on
many cores and i'll explain what that
means i have some results from that and
also part of what we use to get this is
some neural network components and Adam
will be talking about that along with
the work the GK did on parallelizing a
complete yoona stream system and yoona
stream it's just a one stream system
again shortly I'll explain what I mean
Oh in fact right there I'll explain what
I mean this is just kind of a generic
picture of the components of a speech
recognizer everybody uses something like
this of course there's lots more details
inside of each box but basically from
the speech people compute some kind of
signal processing variables those
variables are passed to something that
estimate the probability of
when speech sounds being responsible for
these variables that you have locally
that is say a hundred times a second
little 20 or 30 milliseconds stepped
along every 10 milliseconds these are
going to give you probabilities but the
way that they are able to give you
probabilities is that there are acoustic
parameters which are which come from
models that have been trained on a lot
of data offline and the these local
probabilities are then fed to another
box along with prior information that
you have about the nature of the
language such as how probable it is that
a particular word is is going to follow
two or three or more words and the
composition of a word in terms of those
speech sounds that you were getting the
probabilities for and at the end you get
a stream of words so that's your basic
system and if you've got lots of data to
get all of the training information and
your testing situation is roughly the
same as your training situation this
actually works reasonably well so that's
sort of what I say in this top bullet
here speech recognition works pretty
well under good conditions with
plentiful resources so if you have lots
and lots of training that corresponds to
the way you're going to test it and it's
not loud there's not a lot of noise or a
lot of reverberation you can do pretty
well depending on the task you can do
down to a few percent we recently did a
Mandarin broadcast news task and once we
got enough data over a thousand hours of
data we got the broadcast news down to a
couple percent the other hand Mandarin
broadcast conversation even without any
particular noise reverberation was more
like ten percent so you do get poor much
poorer performance for some conditions
and particularly if you get some
combination of noise and reverberation
and a relaxed conversational kind of
speaking style you can easily get over
thirty percent of the words wrong yes
sir
both ends on the application but if
there's there's human beings generally
don't do particularly better than but if
you actually look at results of for
instance just recognizing numbers by
human beings in a call center after
lunch it's terrible after coffee it's
pretty good thirty percent is acceptable
for some applications for example
information retrieval thirty percent
doesn't have a whole lot of effect
because most of the speech recognition
errors are uh versus stuff in verses on
things that are on the stop list for
which information retrieval anyway so
right so two percent could be not good
enough if you were you know doing
something stupid like trying to control
the scalpel but firing missiles right
yeah then two percent is not good enough
but on the other hand as Adams saying if
you are doing voice search maybe thirty
percent would be good enough but there's
certainly a range of applications where
you'd likely to be much better than
thirty percent and used do have those
kind of numbers for a lot of a lot of
data sets so it what people have already
done is made use of several different
signal processing methods not just
single one in fact a number of the best
systems have two or three different
kinds of ways of looking at the speech
data and they incorporate them in
different ways and they do pretty well
but in general people have found once
you have two or three of these if you go
to a fourth or fifth or sixth you get
diminishing returns so i've been
pursuing sort of the counter view which
is maybe there's a way that you could
use a huge number of them and and
actually get better robustness i'll show
here this is basically the same picture
except we have different signal
processing modules and the reason why i
think this could help is that it could
be that say if you had thousands of
these maybe only need you three or four
but in a different situation
acoustically in terms of speaking style
etc it might be a different three or
four
so where this fits into parallelism well
the front end that I'm imagining is
embarrassingly parallel now as the front
end is now that I'm calling the front
end is the signal processing chunk
saying that you're going to parallel
eyes that through anybody who knows this
field would sort of say yeah why bother
you know because maybe it's ten percent
of the computation but I'm talking about
expanding it out and making it a lots
more computation in which case you
really would need two parallel why's it
in the future in order to get the
throughput and then it would maybe be
ninety percent of the computation
instead of ten percent and I just added
this yesterday I realized that there's a
little bit of an analogy with the
multi-vue you know photosynth stuff that
was discussed yesterday morning that you
have many many different views of the of
the same scene the difference is that at
least as it was described yesterday this
was in order to give you the possibility
of viewing at many different ways
constructing a model and so forth and
here the major reason for it is that
some of these views will be obscured and
you want to take advantage of the ones
that aren't so here's a picture of how
we would expand out the front end right
now with people do is compute something
like an auditory spectrum and what you
mean by auditory varies but essentially
it's a time-frequency plane with a few
auditory properties the one that
everybody uses is that there's less
resolution at high frequencies than at
low frequencies but you might have some
other auditory properties in there and
then you split up the data so there is a
factorization discussed in the last talk
that's one way you could split up the
data the other is just sort of all over
the place do different Gabor filter as
much as is done in vision with different
kinds of scales and range and so forth
and then these the output of these Gabor
filters go into multi-layer perceptrons
and these are trained discriminative ly
so this accomplishes they accomplish two
things first since they are trained
discriminative ly between different
speech sounds they give you features
which are
someone discriminately which are someone
discriminative that they're pretty good
at discriminating between different
speech sounds and the second thing is
they output posterior probabilities of
these different speech sounds and the
nice thing about posterior probabilities
is there's all sorts of cool ways to
combine them so then the the last box
I'll come back to the second last box
but the the last box over there is just
some transformations that we do to make
them nice features for Gaussian mixtures
to model basically make them roughly
orthogonal and roughly Gaussian so the
big questions we sort of knew how to do
all this the big questions come in here
because again I think if you just
combined in a naive way a thousand
different streams or 100 different
streams it's probably not going to work
too well and so you want to do something
that perhaps selects or at the very
least strongly de-emphasizes a lot of
these streams and but the main thing the
main point I want to get at here is that
when I if I was trying to do recognition
on this speech I wouldn't want to have
to have come in here before and trained
up on a thousand hours of other people
speaking in this room you don't have to
do that if you've never been in this
room before you came in here and you're
still able to understand me hopefully
but that's the way we that's where we
are in speech recognition now is that we
have to conduct huge amounts of data to
go for a new new genre new language a
new just a new room and that's that's a
bad situation so the idea is to have
lots of different ways of looking at the
speech and then to be able to switch
between them or combine them in some
good way so I think we'll take a longer
talk to explain why I think this would
work but the engineer practical
engineering thing is that we've tried
some of these ideas out and at least on
a small scale they do work this is a set
of results for numbers recognition
numbers is not just digits numbers
includes things like 16 and 66 1660
which are all pretty similar
our best results are sort of under under
three percent with a sort of standard
system if we add some of these streams
we get a couple percent which is get
getting rid of almost a third of the
errors if we had lots more streams we
clearly don't know how to do that quite
right yet at least for clean data if it
does get a little bit worse but the
noisy case we made this much tougher we
added all kinds of noises with signal
noise ratios varying from 0 to 20 signal
DB signore's ratio and we end up with el
many different it's not white noise it's
many different natural noises speech
babble inside of an f-16 inside of cars
all sorts of things and you end up
worsening by quite a bit by a factor
five and we get rid of about half of the
errors so that that works pretty well
and by the way I want to point out this
is a postdoc of mine Sharia who did did
this work and she's currently extending
from 28 streams 200 streams so at least
for the noisy case which is kind of what
we're trying to get at since for many
applications all of these numbers would
have been okay for clean but but
probably not so much for the noisy case
all those same Assad yeah this is this
is s our eyes yeah we're using SSRIs
decipher which is a pretty advanced game
when you purchase anything yeah yeah
then we went to a larger task still this
case it's not noisy it is some of its
conversational data which is called
broadcast conversation so it's not that
simple the DM FCC baseline is about
twenty five percent and it's about
twenty two percent if we add a few
streams so we haven't gone up to more
streams yet we haven't added noise yet
this is when my students Sue Ann reverie
who's doing this but it does again this
is a clean case so the improvement isn't
as dramatic it's about sixteen percent
you generally see a reduction in in how
much cool techniques help when you go
from a small task to a large task but
it's still it's still there and I think
if we were looking at a noisy case it
would be much bigger okay so how does
this relate to parallel
asian we're going to expand the easy
easy easily parallelizable stuff but
computationally dominant parts at least
in this many stream image feat the
feature streams multi-layer perceptrons
which which take a lot because these are
these are by the way big multi-layer
perceptrons it can be millions of
parameters for each one I should also
mention although I'm talking here about
recognition one of our big concerns for
parallelization is training because
right now it takes us a couple weeks to
Train one of these MLPs and we'd like
that to be an overnight and the
gaussians for the statistical engine
those are all pretty regular and pretty
straightforward to two parallel eyes but
very important then there's
parallelizing a full unit stream system
and this is GK Chong's work that animal
talked about in a moment but ultimately
what we want to do is work with a full
application which we haven't done for
our life yet and of course the reason
why we want to do that take a full
application is because we want to watch
out for armed Ohm's law there may be
other things we're just saying oh that's
not very important and they could kill
us so we want to ultimately end up with
a demo bull version of a complete
meeting die riser or a browser it's a
picture of one that was done part as
part of a European Union project where
you have time moving along here and you
have different speakers so you're
separating out by who's speaking when
and you have a transcription there and
then there's other notes that then go
off to the right such as summarized
ations this the the european when the
Europeans did their collection they also
did video and so there's other video can
be attached to it so these things
already existed at a research level but
again the performance is is at this
point still not all that great we'd like
to improve that and also be able to
handle more ad hoc meetings that might
occur in noisia reverberant environments
ok so again just to give credit sherry
Jean sumon we're very working on this
trying to make things better at
icsi a demand and Chris way works with
him work on making it faster and GK
chung and young man ye are working our
curt quite sir students are working on
this full unit screen system and that's
my part yo yeah sure there's one
back-end recognizer that is running on
multiple streams this is there a reason
for not running multiple back-end
recognizers each on one or a subset of
the streets well I think the notion is
to is to do the combination as early as
possible so that you can you have you
know as good information to pass on
later as possible I mean in a real
system if you are you know facing
something I know you love DARPA kind of
deadlines you might want to partly you
know do some of each like people it for
instance in an SSRI system they they
take the two or three stream system that
we have already and they take another
system that that's y una stream and they
they cross adapt so there's there's
combination here and there's combination
there then they take their system and
combine it at a rover level with aachen
system and so you know in it in a system
where you don't care about how much junk
you throw in there you'll probably do
all sorts of things but I think the
thing we're pursuing not not that
another method wouldn't work is an ocean
it's more like what we think is going on
in I didn't talk about this in a
mammalian auditory cortex primary
auditory cortex where there appear to be
many many different representations and
so the brain does something with that I
don't know what goes on after the
primary third quarter just to add to
that though the other reason also is
that for our lab were more interested in
online in real time whereas for the
competition systems it's all batch
encoding and with a batch you can wait
until you're sort of at the end of you
know a news show and you have an entire
utterance an entire hypothesis that you
then combined
line with another systems entire
hypothesis it's not clear how you
combine at the decoder level if you're
trying to do it online real-time online
so when you explain for once Jim two on
Jim do you expend the particular
spectrum of you spent the number of
gobble filters yeah we expand the
selection of Gabor filters that that go
into a particular stream so one thing is
probably a little wrong about my picture
is that that each of the streams
actually consists of some collection of
Gabor filters outputs and so you can you
could easily expand out to a thousand
given you the combinations of how wide
you make them and and how much of the
spectrum corresponds to what Gabor
filter and so on but right now you know
28 to 100 is all we're doing but the
auditory spectrum is it's just it's just
the base that we work from and then you
you take chunks of it and run Gabor
filters typically initially we run the
the same Gabor filter on all parts of
the spectrum but we could change that in
auditory elvis's people did you think
about having different aspect of the
obvious special like a great synchrony
you know all this there's a lot of space
yeah so so I think I thought I think of
auditory spec Tory and in this context
is meaning whatever people haven't
implemented yet right in real systems
rights because you know p 0 p is
auditory but everybody has p 0 p so they
don't think of it as auditory anymore so
I I meant this in just the broadest
possible sense that there's some kind of
time frequency plane that has some
aspects of auditory ideas in it you know
Shep shamma and his stuff has tended to
put in more than we're doing right now
right now we're just taking a Mel's a
log mail spectrum more or less but in
but but I'm I'm open to the idea that
maybe putting more auditory more
auditory aspects in there might make
things better I have no idea okay Adam
so I'm Adam denon I'm going to talk a
little bit about some other parts of the
system i'm going to start with the
multi-layer perceptron or neural network
so the neural network is a machine
learning algorithm just that just Maps
some
floating point inputs to some floating
point outputs and in our case we're
mapping speech features of some sort you
know for those of you are familiar Mel
spectral features or PLP features and so
on and we're trying to map that to
speech sounds is it a cook or is it a
tough we do that every 10 milliseconds
now in a picture like this with one
neural net even though our neural nets
are quite large you know 16,000 32,000
hidden units as Morgan said it doesn't
take up that much compute time so the
reason we're interested in parallelizing
it is first to handle the the sorts of
many many streams that Morgan talked
about in his part but then also during
training we train on thousands and
thousands of hours and it can take a
month to train a big network and we'd
like to cut that down so that we can run
many more experiments and try different
different types of neural networks and
different types of features so what I'm
showing here to just describe what the
computation looks like is we have an
input feature which might be I don't
know 39 features each one is connected
by a weight which is just a floating
point number to a hidden layer and so
the operation the mathematical operation
here is a matrix times a vector and then
you perform a nonlinear operation at the
hidden layer and then you repeat to the
output layer in a real system it's a
little more complex than that because we
batch up all these 39th features into
one frame and then we include in that
not just the current time but the for
future times in the four previous times
and so in this picture here each one of
these as the 39 features and we have
nine frames of them but it's still a
matrix times one long vector it's just
the vector is much longer now because
it's looking at a log longer time frame
and we do that because the way you say a
speech sound depends on the context it's
in it's not just the currents how you
say it is not dependent on just the
sound you're trying to say but the sound
previous and the press sound next in
addition to that we also for efficiency
reasons take up up to 10 seconds of
these and bash them all together into
what's called a bunch and that allows
you to do a matrix matrix operation
rather than a matrix vector operation
and that's of course much more efficient
at runtime the call
of doing the grouping the bunching
rather is latency you have to wait until
you've gathered them all up however
that's not really too much of a big deal
because you typically have some latency
introduced waiting for a word to finish
anyway and so introducing a few seconds
of latency at this point isn't a real
problem the bunch sizes change the
training in that you're now optimizing
for something slightly different than
you would if you did it one at a time
but in practice you get the same results
either way it's not very sensitive to
that and the matrix matrix operation is
much more efficient and so in terms of
parallelization we already have an
existing optimized multi multi core
implementation called quick net that was
developed at it see years ago and has
been parallelized sort of over over time
for existing cluster computers is we use
that quite a lot at XE and other places
as well have used it we've also
developed a CUDA implementation and it
gets about three times the speed that
quick net currently gets I don't have a
unit processor number on what the speed
up is over a single thread just because
we just never run it that way anymore
but I certainly could if we if people
were interested in what that what that
is now once we optimize the matrix
matrix multiply the computational bottom
like actually ended up being a
combination of assembling the data for
the context windows and the
non-linearity and so we address that by
doing a fast approximate exponential on
the eight core version and then
fortunately CUDA has a built-in
parallelized exponential and so we use
that on CUDA and so with those
optimizations we're now compute bound
for any large net which is what we
typically run so you know as long as
you're running a net with thousands of
hidden units we're completely
computation bound on these platforms the
next topic is something we're working on
currently called a tonne a topic network
and it's called tonotopic because we
organize the features roughly by tone so
these features down at the bottom are
low frequency it's the how much energy
is there in the low frequency part of
the spectrum and the higher up ones or
how much energy is in the higher parts
of the spectrum and we organize the
neural
network in a structured way so that
we're computing directly on energy on
frequency bands so the reason we think
this might work is for example imagine
you have band-limited noise where at one
frequency band some there's something
going on that corrupts it the network
could learn that and not get it be
interfered with other the clean part of
the spectrum additionally we've also
found that combining things like this
with other systems typically pretty much
always works so just having something
that's a little different from the
others from the other systems that you
have gives you better accuracy and as
you can see the structure of this is
going to be a little different in terms
of the computations first of all we've
added an additional layer but that's
just a dense matrix multiply again in
terms of the input layer then the
structure in the input layer the pumps
aren't just stayed that way one way of
implementing this would be as a block
diagonal matrix where the ones where
there no connections are just zeros but
that's not very efficient so it's in
fact what we end up doing is separate
matrix multiplies for each grouping and
that's just a more efficient way of
organizing it and then also there's the
context window issue that I described
before which makes just the the sort of
organization of the data here a little
more complex you have to move things
around a lot more and that just takes a
little more time so we have already an
existing single core version that's that
we used a Dixie that got written by when
I graduate students that graduated last
year and we've been working on the multi
and many core implementations are
currently in progress and we expect
similar speed up it's probably not going
to be quite as good because you have
slightly smaller matrices and doing
several of them but it should be pretty
close so next I want to go on to talking
about a the work of GK Chong and other
people other students at par lab on
doing a parallelized decoder so this is
the component that once all the signal
processing stuff has been done then you
have some features it theoretically does
a search over all possible utterances in
your language and outputs the one
that matches your data the best of
course it can't do every possible
utterance that's too many so it does a
huge search a huge pruned search and in
typical single threaded yeah that single
stream ASR systems that's the
computational bottleneck is this search
and so it's useful to paralyze it so
that you can get real-time response and
just get a faster faster system response
the other components of this the
pronunciation lexicon the acoustic
parameters in the language model were
generously donated by sr I for this
project they've been simplified a little
bit from what we would run as a full
system both to fit in memory because we
have some memory constraints on the GPUs
and also because again we're
concentrating more on online in real
time systems so the full-blown SSRI
system does many many many passes over
the data and sort of assumes you have
the entire utterance available before
you do any processing at all and it does
adaptation and all sorts of other things
and so for this project we're we're
using simplified systems with fewer
parameters and so on so that's just a
little different and then the work
involved exploring a design space of how
to design the decoder for different
architectures potentially for different
architectures the inference engine
itself is a highly hierarchical
structure the outer loop of it is
organized time synchronously this isn't
the only way to do it other decoders do
it differently but basically you're
moving forward ten milliseconds at a
time and so you're looking basically at
a time synchronous guesses at what this
the stream might be and updating them
all at the same time and that's what the
outer loop looks like the the next loop
in is consists of three three phases the
first phase is basically the computation
of the acoustic models it's a gaussian
mixture computation that you're doing
for all your current hypothesis and this
is completely compute bound and
embarrassingly parallel but it's it's
well not embarrassing i shouldn't say
that's a little more complex than that
but it's easy to pair reasonable
paralyzed compared to phase 2 & 3 which
involve keeping track of your updates
and again because you can't search every
possible hypothesis you have to just
keep track of the best ones and to do
that the hypotheses have to communicate
with each other to keep the updates in
order and I'll talk a little bit about
that in another slide the the hardware
platforms that we ran this on our a
multi-core conventional and then also
the the many core Nvidia's platform and
I think people are probably familiar
with these architectures already but you
can see what the sort of performances
look like and so this slide is sort of
the punchline of the best system and I'm
going to go into a little more detail
later and it's a breakdown of the time
spent in the compute intensive phase
versus of communication intensive phase
so basically the whites are the phase 2
and 3 and the black is phase one and as
you can see the speed-up varies as we go
from the sequential implementation to
the multi-core in the many core all all
the phases are speeded up but the
communication phases are sped up less
than the compute intensive phases and so
this does indicate that without some
additional effort will probably start
hitting some diminishing returns on the
communication phase since we're already
up to fifty percent in the many court
case and then in terms of why the
inference inference engine gk calls it
an inference engine we typically call it
a decoder same thing why it's
challenging the way that the decode runs
is on a graph called a weighted finite
state transducer and the way you should
think of this is it encodes the sort of
words you can say and the patterns and
their pronunciations so this might be
for example up tix and this might be F X
right so it's sharing the suffix and
this might be optometry and you're
proceeding through that as a hypothesis
you can think of particular hypothesis
as just being a spot in the graph that
encodes the path it took to get there
and the
state step is just to move one step
forward in the graph either going to the
next speech sound or staying in the
speech sound you're in and so the graph
is not regular as you can see it's just
guided by what your dictionary looks
like and then where your hypotheses
happen to be on the graph depends on
what happens at runtime how you say the
words what the acoustic environment is
and so on and then of course there's the
problem of synchronization between the
phases as you update the hypotheses so
we investigated a particular design
space on for the traversal and that for
the computation and this slide describes
that so the first choices are sort of
how you bunch up hypothesis hypotheses
to go to the different course you can
either organize them so that you're
going over arcs or you can go over notes
and of course there are a lot more arch
than there are nodes and so what you
would expect is that as you get more
simdi resources more parallel resources
in all likelihood the arcs
implementation is going to be better
than the state's implementation but it
does depend on how many threads you have
excuse me on how many yeah now how many
independent threads you have and then
the the other design axis is on
traversal methods and this is basically
how you communicate and update the
current hypotheses when you're moving
from one state to the next and you can
either do that by propagation which
basically depends on some hardware
locking or you can do it by aggregation
into the final states which in the
current implementation is done with some
software locks and depend so we actually
develop four different algorithms and
ran them on the different platforms to
see which one would work best on each
platform and so this slide basically
shows the breakdown in the different
phases for the sequential implementation
and then here for each of the other
implementations and basically along this
axis if you have platform atomix you do
better in this axis and as you have more
simdi do better on that axis and so on
the multi core platform these are what
the results we had and as
you can see the you definitely want to
do the project propagation rather than
an aggregation on the multi-core setup
but there's not a whole lot of
difference between the arc based and the
state-based because you don't have a lot
of simdi lanes and so it's not not a
huge advantage to do one over the other
and so state-based propagation won by a
little bit over the other algorithms the
picture is slightly different on the
many core where the breakdown looks more
like this and you as you can see here
the art based propagation won by a lot
and you're still better off with
propagation because both platforms have
good hardware locks but on the many core
architecture you have a lot more Cindy
resources and so yours there's a much
better win on using the arc based
propagation and I think that's all I
want to say about the decoder and then
we just have a summary slide so as we
talked about before speech work speech
recognition works pretty well under
meant some conditions but skill can fail
quite badly if you have noise if you
have accents if you have unexpected
conditions in in various ways human to
human communications and by massively
expanding the front end we hope to
address some of those issues to do
better and noise to be more robust to
unknown situations to be better with
less training data and then the power
lab approach has helped quite a bit on
making the individual components much
faster and so the enabling us to do a
lot more experimentation as well as to
run in real time and then the final
point is how can par lab tools enable
more experimentation this gets again at
the whole point that right now a
training of one of our big Nets can take
a month and what we'd like to do is be
able to train up 100 nets and be able to
do it in a day and be able to experiment
with many many more features Morgan did
you want to add anything else to the
summary slide
right now we're using our own homegrown
software right hand because these things
are proceeding in parallel the software
frameworks etc developments happening in
our lab and out of work and speech we're
not using any that's
and be giving nice to see if as that
stuff develops further
I'm time at the mainstream sort of other
XE researchers yeah do you know of
whether some the pair town of the SI
decoders components to enable all this
power computation done by jamie chung
yeah how much does it reduce the
components after you pedal most
important email that you I don't have it
off the top of my head it was aight i
believe around four or five percent how
their to power well again the issue the
the most of the reduction had to do with
just Finnegan in memory on the on the
nvidia card we wanted to be able to have
a fair comparison between the nvidia
card and the multi multi stream system
and so we just had to take for example
language models that were much more
heavily pruned than we normally would so
the language models just smaller than it
would be for our full-grown system which
parts of the application you really want
to run locally on your end
it seems like the training might be done
yeah absolutely so the training almost
certainly you do all your training on a
cloud you might do some adaptation
locally and then in terms of runtime AC
is participated a little bit in some of
the distributed speech recognition tasks
the idea being that you do some of the
computation on your phone basically all
the front end stuff and then you ship
that all off digitally to a back-end
rather than just either shipping audio
from your phone which introduces its own
set of artifacts or trying to do all the
recognition on your phone but I think as
the processing power gets greater and
greater you'll see more and more of it
migrating all the way down to your phone
for some tests you can do that already I
think most of you probably have cell
phones that will do voice dialing
already and that works perfectly fine
because it's right against your mouth
it's in a quiet environment and the
vocabulary is small but if you put the
same thing on the center of a table when
you try to record a meeting you wouldn't
get half the words right with the
current technology lets dangerous you
want to take a break